Oh,
how did you calculate your nutrition?
So the nutrition journey was actually
fascinating and to be honest,
in my opinion, people said, well,
well how come other people die trying?
Or why do other people
not be able to do it?
Because one other guy ran out of food.
And so when I was looking at this journey,
you know, we're getting, we're
calling it the impossible first.
Like how am I going to make
the impossible possible?
And I thought that the nutrition piece
of it was going to be huge. I actually,
my dad's an organic farmer in Hawaii,
like whole food health and nutrition has
been a big part of my personal journey.
And so I found a company, um, that
was really, we're in it with me.
So this company called standard process,
their whole food supplement company,
I'm really involved in
Chiropractic and acupuncture.
And they presented them with this and
I said, hey, what do you guys think?
Like is there a way to like figure
this out? And they're like, well,
we have 20 of the top doctors,
nutritionists, food scientists, you know,
on our staff and this innovation
center around nutrition,
like come in the lab with us.
And so they'd never done this with an
athlete before, but they were intrigued.
And so I actually went and did a
year's long worth of, you know,
a hundred plus blood test,
vo two Max test,
all this fitness testing
all around my physiology.
And they created ultimately a
custom food solution as a bar form,
essentially called the column Bar. That
was all whole food ingredients. It was no,
you know, chemical to rivers or anything.
It was, you know, coconut oil, you know,
seeds, nuts, you know,
all these different pieces
of macronutrients as well
as micro nutrient blends
that I needed. But custom tailored to
my physiology. And that's what I mean.
That was the bulk of what I ate.
I ate 7,000 calories per day.
I was burning 10,000 so even at 7,000
I was losing about a pound of day,
a way of weight almost to my body's.
That's why I needed to get bigger.
But these column bars just burned
super efficiently and my body,
like it was just the
perfect blend of everything.
So eating the same thing every single day
for 54 days might have gotten a little
bit boring, but my body was just,
it was actually pretty dialed in.
Wow.
Now when they did this and they,
they made these custom bars for
you, did they know him? I mean,
how did you know how many calories
you're going to be burning while you're
pulling this 300 pound sled?
Was it dependent upon the conditions?
Like if the snow was more
packed or IC would be difficult?
If it was some soft right.
100% so I mean we had to do as our best
guests, honestly, we had to just say,
let's use our best gas. I, you guys had
a bunch of smart people smarter than me.
We're in this room, all these
doctors, these PhDs around this.
And we had to make some assumptions
and ultimately they were like, okay,
you're going to burn 10,000 calories.
Let's get you 10,000
calories in these bars.
And we started running the weight
on the sled and we're like,
that'll be a 500 pound sled.
Like we can't carry that.
So it's this equation of like,
can you make this led light enough to
pull if we can get the nutrition right.
How efficiently does that burn in your
body? How much can your stomach absorb?
You're hungry the whole time. More
or less? Yeah. Fuck yeah, I was,
I was ready for a big fucking meal. I got
done. What's the first thing you ate? Uh,
this, the first thing I ate when
I got back was a big burger.
But you might call me lame for saying
this, but I'm just going to say,
cause it's the truth.
What I craved, salad man.
What I craved was just something cause
I needed this. You know what I mean?
I've been eating like this freeze dried
field, this chunk of Colombar Bar,
which got me through,
but it was like something green and
alive until I let miss big salad with
avocado and Sally. No, I had a big
burger too, but then of course I eat,
my stomach is shrunk, right. I eat
this big meal and I'm like, oh,
my stomach kind of hurts.
But emotionally I was like,
I'm back in the real world
baby. So it was like, it was,
I did everything I could get my hands.
I went to a buffet and just like my
stomach was hurting, but I was like,
I'm not going to stop.
And I just started eating like
whatever croissants and bread,
it was all the things.
So I would imagine your body would like
you probably craving all that life.
Like live things green.
Exactly. Vegetables and fruit.
It's weird to say, I mean like I'm
from Portland, Oregon, you know,
it's pretty green part of the world
up there in the Pacific northwest.
And so not even just the food component,
but there's nothing alive out there.
There's no animals on the coast.
There are. But like in the interior,
and I don't see any animals. I don't see
a bird. I didn't see, you know, nothing.
Right.
And so not only have,
I think as humans we're kind
of wired to see things living.
I mean even here in la,
but have a concrete jungle.
But like you see trees on the street,
you see the, Oh shit. Yeah, whatever.
That's what a Nazi, anything alive
for 54 days. It was like, wow,
I want to like smell treats, fresh
air, the trees. I want to eat a salad.
I don't know.
Like that's where I'm like,
my mind got to is kind of coming
back to reality and that way.